[Applause]
so
[Applause]
[Music]
so
isn't it
there's a serial killing
i want your perspective
first anniversary is paper
what makes you think i'm so cheap
i thought you'd be curious
you think i cut off this stuff
don't you
you have pictures
[Applause]
hey
it's violence
it's so broke
he likes little puzzles doesn't he
so ridiculous
like he's been planning this his whole
life
i know who he is
oh
[Music]
oh is he
he's a nobody
wants to be somebody
that's the
the
mayor
yeah
he's got ambition
you think his motive is political oh no
this is very very personal
he feels these people have all walked
him
probably goes way back
unhealed wounds stolen much money
why is he writing to me
maybe
he's a fan of yours
or maybe he's got a grudge against you
too
maybe you're the main course
any theories
oh yeah really
you're normally so headless
but something is different
this time
this is very upsetting to you let's get
back to him why
you are so much more fun i'm not here to
talk about me what are you here to talk
about i want to know how he thinks you
know exactly how he thinks have you read
this file
you two have so much in common
masked adventures
so he's even more righteous
are you afraid he makes you look soft
wasting my time
about his motors whether he loves or
hates you
i think somewhere deep down
you're just terrified
because you're not sure he's wrong huh
you think they deserved it
you think they deserved it
[Applause]
you